In this tutorial, you'll learn how to modify an intercepted request in BERT proxy.
This enables you to manipulate the request in ways that the website isn't expecting
in order to see how it responds.
Using one of our deliberately vulnerable websites, known as Labs, you'll see how this can help
you identify and exploit real vulnerabilities.
To follow along, you'll need an account on portswigger.net.
If you don't have one already, registration is free and it grants you full access to the
Web Security Academy.
In BERT, go to the Proxy Intercept tab and make sure Intercept is switched off.
Launch BERT's browser and use it to visit the following lab.
The lab is entitled, Excessive Trust in Client Side Controls.
When the page loads, click Access the lab.
If prompted, log into your portswigger.net account.
After a few seconds, you'll see your own instance of a fake shopping website.
On the shopping website, click My Account and log in using the following credentials.
Username, Winer, password, Peter.
You can check these out on the accompanying tutorial on our website.
When you log into the account, notice that you have just $100 of store credit.
Click Home to go back to the home page.
Select the option to view the product details for a lightweight leather jacket.
In BERT, go to the Proxy Intercept tab and switch Interception On.
In the browser, add the leather jacket to your cart to intercept the resulting post forward
slash cart request.
You may initially see a different request on the Proxy Intercept tab if the browser is doing
something else in the background.
In this case, just click forward until you see the post request generated when you click
the Add Cart button.
Study the intercept request and notice that there is a parameter in the body called price, which
matches the price of the item in cents.
Click into this parameter and change the value to 1.
Then click forward to send the modified request to the server.
Switch Interception off again so that any subsequent requests can pass through BERT proxy uninterrupted.
In BERT's browser, click the basket icon in the upper right corner to view your cart.
Notice that the jacket has been added for just one cent.
There is no way to modify the price via the web interface.
You were only able to make this change thanks to BERT proxy.
Click the place order button to purchase the jacket for an extremely reasonable price.
Congratulations, you've just sold your first Web Security Academy lab.
You've also learned how to intercept, review, and manipulate HTTP traffic using BERT proxy.
Click the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link to the link.
Thank you.